bengals have had a proud tradition of
quarterbacks from Ken Anderson to Boomer
Esiason to Andy Dalton to Carson Palmer
almost forgot about him Ken Anderson the
quarterback back in the 70s took to
Twitter yesterday after Andy Dalton was
cut by the Bengals and said that Andy
has represented the city of Cincinnati
and the Bengals quarterback family with
class and success both on and off the
field
I'm proud to call him a friend and wish
him nothing but the best of luck
wherever he goes we'll be lucky to have
him hashtag who day the Bengals had made
the strategic decision to move on they
tried to trade and they held on to him
maybe longer than they should have but
hey when you're in the last year of a
second contract there rarely are the
kind of triggers in there that will
force the team's hand the team had the
right just like the Panthers did with
Cam Newton although I didn't agree with
that either to squat on the guy and the
music has long stopped on the starting
quarterback carousel and now Andy Dalton
like Cam Newton like Joe Flacco like
Jameis Winston up until a few days ago
have to sit and wait and see what's out
there but the thing is and the
difference is between Dalton and Cam
Newton I think Dalton will take a backup
job if that's all he can get cams gonna
wait for a starting opportunity and he
should
but Dalton the other you start looking
at the teams there's a lot of potential
landing spots where he could upgrade the
depth chart and help a younger
quarterback get the most out of his
skills baquette absolutely absolutely
the other difference between a Dalton
and Cam Newton is if you believe that
teams aren't actually sending doctors to
give physicals the Andy Dalton probably
doesn't need the same type of you know
scrutiny when it comes to a physical
versus Cam Newton who has a lot of
question marks depending on how much
money's your own but I agree with you
when you look at the backup quarterback
position it's it's kind of an irrelevant
position for the most part in the NFL
obviously you look at Nick Foles and be
like hey Nick Foles went and won a Super
Bowl that was the outlier most teams if
they lose their starting quarterback the
seasons kind of over but if you have a
guy like Andy Dalton he is a Teddy
Bridgewater like guy from last year
where the Saints were able to win games
without Drew Brees keep the boat afloat
so to speak and keep moving forward for
their long-term plans and I think that
is an attractive option for any team out
there that is thinking Super Bowl this
because if you're thinking Super Bowl
this year and you get even a passion
from a Holmes platformer Holmes was out
for longer than the three weeks or
whatever he missed having Andy Dalton is
a heck of a lot better than having an
unproven you know six round pick or a
guy career backup who's just there to be
a good teammate in the locker room like
chase Daniel not a ricochet shot because
I actually think chase Daniel serves a
purpose for what he does in terms of
being that good team leader and teammate
but if you're trying to win
Andy Dalton is the guy that you want is
your backup well and big cat Howie
Roseman the Eagles Jim makes that point
by pointing to the mahomes situation
from last year because the Chiefs went 2
& 1 while mahomes was out with Matt
Moore if they lose one of those games
they don't have the number one seed and
then all of a sudden the path to the
Superbowl is a lot more treacherous and
difficult so whether it's five games
like Teddy Bridgewater played whether
it's three games like Matt Moore played
whether it's quarterback goes down in
mid-december and the backup has to do
the nick foles routine all the way
through to the Super Bowl you need to
have a number two that you feel good
about and one thing I've noticed in
recent years there was a period where
there weren't enough quality starting
quarterbacks to go around there are now
the question is are there enough quality
backups to go around and there aren't
and here's Andy Dalton available and you
can get him now you can get him at
probably a reasonable price and so the
question becomes which team is going to
be the one to take a depth chart that
they kind of already thought was set
although they'd have been foolish if
they weren't at least considering the
possibility that Dalton's going to be
free and clear after they drafted Joe
burrow in Cincinnati but now you have to
ask yourself do we take what we have and
disrupt it by bringing in Andy Dalton as
the number two behind our starter or or
in a place like New England which
reportedly wasn't interested in Dalton
when he was under contract now that he's
available does Bill Belichick say well
okay Jared Stidham Andy Dalton Jared
Stidham Andy Dalton I'm gonna go with
Andy Dalton now Mike let me ask you this
about the backup quarterback
the current free agents and Cam Newton
and Andy Dalton sitting as we stand
right here on May 1st is there any in
again this is not reporting at all
everyone knows a lot a reporter but I
feel like at least I've heard this is
there any truth behind owners saying to
themselves let's hold off on signing
someone until we know if we're playing a
full season or not let's not go pay
someone a bunch of money on a signing
bonus which might not be Andy Dalton's
case Moore Cam Newton's until we are
guaranteed that we are playing a full
season and giving this money makes sense
is there anything to do with that
because it still is a little shocking to
me the Cam Newton's is a free agent I
think with Cam Newton the bigger
impediment is not being able to
determine that he's healthy not to have
your doctors put their hands on him and
their eyes on him and understand that
the ankles find that the foots fund the
shoulders find that there's nothing else
that they don't know about from all
those years of playing in a way that
suggests he's indestructible when we've
learned that he's far from
indestructible one injury at a time so I
think that's the impediment I've been
poking around this idea of what teams
are doing to protect themselves against
the possibility that won't be a season
and they're all operating under the
impression that there's gonna be
something and I've yet to get the sense
that anyone is deliberately restricting
paying out money due to the possibility
that that there won't be a season in
fact I thought most teams wouldn't sign
their rookie draft picks some of the
people I've talked to their attitude is
hey we're going forward we're gonna
treat it like any other year now the
owner may say otherwise
but I don't think that's an impediment I
think the impediment is two things one
making sure he's healthy and 2 what do
you do with him he's gonna want a lot of
money you're gonna have to make him the
starter which team out there at this
point could say to Cam Newton here
you're the guy I mean the Chargers were
one but they have Justin Herbert so
they're off the list
you know the Patriots it's never felt
like a match there Scott Pioli the
former VP of player personnel in New
England said several weeks ago he
doesn't see Bill Belichick and Cam
Newton meshing so I think for cam he's
just got to sit and wait for somebody to
get injured whether it's been rather
hundred
it's Berg again somebody gets injured
and then there's a demand for Cam Newton
for Andy Dalton he's gonna find a spot
and uh yeah and now look you're not
missing anything now cuz there's no
offseason program you're missing zoom
conferences that's it but I just don't I
don't think that that the money is the
issue from the perspective of we may not
have a season I'm not saying it
shouldn't be but I have yet to get the
indication that it is ok so then
follow-up question what
why did Jameis sign for so little and I
know he was saying I know there were
reports that he had bigger offers but it
seems like to me the Saints at that
price when you see the price you know
written out you're like okay the Saint
said if we don't have a season who cares
this is such a little amount of money
for a guy who was you know the number
one pick five years ago and yeah Jameis
has a lot of detractors and rightfully
so with 30 interceptions last year but
if we go back to the conversation we
just had about a quarterback being able
to keep the boat afloat if your starter
goes down
I think Jameis has a higher ceiling in
that respect than a lot of team's
backups and any team that's competing
for a Super Bowl next year would want a
backup like that versus a backup who
might not be able to keep a team afloat
if the starter does go down so that that
whole thing made no sense to me that he
got paid so little and it besides the
fact that an owner saying OK for 1
million yeah we'll do it what let's just
do it well I think that there is a
not-so-subtle psychology to dealing with
Jameis Winston and the Saints waited for
the right time to swoop in and get this
deal done post draft no takers for
Jameis Winston no starting jobs and he
went through that period and I think he
had to work through that period where
once for agency starts and no one comes
after him and he's waiting and he's
waiting and at some point he has to come
to the conclusion on his own it's over
for me right now from the standpoint of
a starter I need to find a place where I
can rebuild things and the obvious
landing spot the Saints when you
consider what happened with Teddy
Bridgewater two years there next thing
you know he's got a three years 66
million dollar contract in Carolina
can't Jameis Winston's made forty five
million in five years with the
Buccaneers 60
six over three is a great outcome if he
can get it and going there and learning
offense from Sean Payton and Drew Brees
it was the perfect time you could argue
maybe he'd be better off long haul
sitting and waiting for someone to get
injured but you know what Cam Newton's
gonna be the first guy that gets called
when that happens so you got to wait for
two guys to get injured now before
you're back in so I think that's what it
was it's not the money it's Jameis
Winston finally coming to the conclusion
that he's not gonna be a starter this
year and his best play to become a
starter again is to play for the Saints
so a recap of the backup quarterback
Carousel Andy Dalton is a my frozen a my
frozen now you're fine you're fine okay
I'm frozen on my end but as long as I
can is you can hear me I'm gonna power
through Andy Dalton going to get signed
soon as a backup cam newton might have
to wait until the season starts and
there is that emergency Wow our season
could get derailed because our starting
quarterback just got hurt yeah and Joe
Flacco will just wait and wait and wait
and wait and wait
yeah definite and Blake bortles should
be signed yesterday
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports